-Welcome back, everybody.
We're hanging out with
the one and only
Michael Strahan!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, we always like to do
something a little competitive
when you're on the show,
so I thought it would be fun
to go head-to-head with
some 30-second challenges.
It is time for "30 Seconds To."
-♪ 30 seconds to ♪
-This first challenge --
we have 30 seconds to try
and stack these cranberry sauces
into a pyramid.
Whoever finishes their pyramid
first wins the challenge.
Are you a cranberry sauce dude
on Thanksgiving?
-Yes, I am.
-Can or fresh?
-Can is always consistent.
I'm not gonna lie.
And I like cutting
along the lines.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, I'm not the only one.
I know it.
[ Laughter ]
-I like it too, yeah.
I like it when my sauce has abs.
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
We're gonna get 30 seconds
on the clock.
We're gonna have to make
a pyramid out of these.
-A pyramid? So you have to
use every one, right?
-Yes, you have to use
every one of these.
Alright. You ready?
-Yeah.
-Set, go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
This is going to be tough.
[ Cheers and applause ]
What are you doing, man?
You know what's up, dude.
Come on, bud.
What's going on?
-Do they have --
-Come on. Yeah, you can do it.
You can let it go.
-Hold on, hold up, 4.
Aaah!
[ Laughter ]
-No, you got that.
You got to give it right there.
Points. No, respect.
Respect to Michael Strahan
right there.
You can take that away.
-There you go.
-Ooh, that tastes good.
-Can't wait to what's next.
-Alright. Here we go. Alright.
This next challenge, we're going
to have 30 seconds to see
who can get a meat thermometer
the hottest by blowing onto it
as fast as we can.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Dude, you had a great reputation
up to this point.
So, these are meat thermometers.
So it's a real one.
67 degrees in here.
-Why is mine 64 1/2?
I'm already started --
-Nah, 'cause you're cool.
-All I got to say is whoever
came up with this stuff
needs to really get a life.
[ Laughter ]
-It was me. Alright. Here we go.
Let's get 30 seconds
on the clock.
I don't know how to do it.
Ready?
How do we do it?
Ready? Sorry. Set.
-No, you're not starting
a campfire like that.
-Alright, hold on.
Where you at now?
I'm 75 already.
-60 -- 70.
-Alright. Here we go. Ready?
Ready, set, go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Coughing ]
[ Jimmy yelling ]
♪♪
[ Buzzer ]
What do we got?
83, wow!
-Yeah!
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I almost died on that,
by the way.
-I thought we were going to,
like, pass out.
[ Laughter ]
But, you know, everybody always
says, you're full of hot air.
Now I know I am.
-Alright, not bad. Good job.
-There we go.
-Alright, perfect.
Now we're down to
our final challenge.
Man, I'm light-headed
right here.
Yeah, we have 30 seconds
to see who can toss
the most ears of corn
into our mouths.
It's literal corn hole.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Whoever --
Whoever gets the most corn
in the hole...
[ Laughter ]
...wins the round
and the whole game.
-It's like always something
with the gap, man.
Always.
[ Laughter ]
-You ready for this?
Let's try this.
Get 30 seconds on the clock.
Congratulations. Good luck.
Whoever wins this
wins the whole thing.
-I'm going to tell my mom
to go to bed early tonight.
[ Laughter ]
-On your mark, get set, go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Oh, come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Buzzer ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Michael Strahan!
-Yeah!
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on!
Michael Strahan, the champ.
His Michael Strahan Daily
Defense skin care is available
on Amazon and
michaelstrahanskin.com.
Chef Daniel Humm joins us
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.